mise en scène en pleine forêt de satory
à versailles ce mardi 21 juin la section
technique de l'armée de terre présentait
à la presse ces nouveaux matériels ce
centre expert dans le domaine des
équipements individuels du combattant
est à l'origine du nouveau camouflage il
équipera l'armée de terre dès 2024
le principe de ce camouflage c'est que
avec un seul trait nous allons pouvoir
être envoyé en opérations extérieures
dans les zones africaines un petit peu
partout dans le monde et également
pouvoir faire les opérations intérieures
sentinelle mais également éventuellement
des opérations dans le ce qu'on appelle
le centre europe c'est-à-dire dans un
environnement beaucoup plus sombre une
logistique facilité grâce à un
camouflage unique et un gain de
performance de 25% le dessin a été
réalisé ici également le développement
des couleurs puisque en fait les goûts
leur sont spécifiques et original et
nous avons mené un certain d'évaluation
dans divers pays du monde pour pouvoir
développer des couleurs adaptées à ce
que nous voulions réaliser la section
technique de l'armée de terre est aussi
à l'origine de la nouvelle génération de
gilet pare balles un historique de ces
équipements étaient présentées jusque
dans les années 90 la protection et est
dissociée du gilet de combat au début on
mettait l'un ou l'autre puis après on a
1000 1 et par dessus l'autre voilà mais
d'un point de vue ergonomie ça c'était
pas extraordinaire ce nouveau gilet
pare-balles sera modulaire le soldat
pour apprendre avec lui tout le matériel
dont il a besoin comme ces munitions ou
sa radio nous avons mis en place une
protection balistique en 2016 et pendant
un an et demi nous avons fait les
retours d'expériences opération pour
pouvoir aujourd'hui mettre en place la
nouvelle structure modulaire balistique
version 2 qui va équiper les soldats à
partir de 2022 responsable d'environ 400
projets par an la section technique de
l'armée de terre emploi 395 personnes
sur le site de satory